from a distance lucelle stadium looks
ready in a city that didn't exist a
decade ago Qatar will open the World Cup
next month
but where 80 000 fans will arrive
low-paid Mica workers are still digging
toiling in 40 degree heat ruling
conditions as kickoff approaches and
pressure grows from English and Welsh
football leaders to ensure compensation
for the injured and families of workers
who died
as the un's labor agency leads scrutiny
and Doha of how more than 100 billion
pounds in infrastructure has been built
I think there are mechanisms in place
that can be further strengthened the
government in in from 2019 established a
workers fund which has paid out so far
160 million dollars to over 37 000
workers so that really demonstrates the
scale of the problem in terms of wage
related abuses it takes a trip into a
village in Nepal to see the anguish
caused by qatar's compensation
shortcomings and the sense of loss
reinforced by the lack of full
investigations into deaths of workers
like cashier in Belle base a 32 year old
who was working on the construction of
qatar's Metro leaving a widow and his
daughter and son
grieving
oil is
now to Carla Bell base is without her
husband's salary only receiving
outstanding pay after fatal respiratory
failure she fears was caused by working
in extreme heat rather than an
underlying health condition
s
a family Grieves far from the glitz of
Qatar where the world's biggest stars
will soon be playing we've been trying
to facilitate the role that football
associations can play in doing their due
diligence but also engaging with worker
management committees in their hotels
and also with the other contractors that
they they engage with during the World
Cup we feel that this is you know beyond
just doing a checklist to check that you
know all these labor rights are are in
place with with the contractors you know
they need to talk to workers talk to the
worker representatives in the hotels to
find out you know what are the actual
challenges or the issues that they face
perhaps there are challenges perhaps
there are success stories
in the face heat the final touches are
being made to ensure Qatar is World Cup
ready migrant workers who have suffered
so much hope in this tournament can
still bring change Rob Harris Sky News
Qatar